let's go next to our caller from the
three two three area code who's calling
today from three to three one of you
Bobby let me see come with us
we are moving gracias one of the I'm
coming from Los Angeles my name is
Manuel Antonio Rodriguez I want to talk
to you about over in lips uber and lyft
drivers okay
so yesterday there was a big rally
outside of the LA City Council they
approved a measure to look into possibly
painting
uber and lyft drivers $30 an hour in the
City of LA I guess I kind of just wanted
to hear you from that and the idea
behind this is that you know $15 would
go towards your wages and then $15 that
go towards maintaining the car because
as you may or may not know that many you
know listeners may not know we're not
you know compensated or we're not you
know reimbursed for any gas car
maintenance and you know other things
that go along with you know I mean
cleaning your car and driving it right
and sorry I guess I just kinda want to
hear your thoughts on that and then more
tying that into yesterday's debate I
guess I wanted to hear what your
thoughts are on Kamla Harris because she
did you know spill out a line out there
what she did say you know workers
shouldn't have to work a full-time job
and then drive an uber you know after
their full time job and I guess I want
to know what your thoughts on that since
she does have you know some of her
political strategist and family are very
closely tied with uber I you know I I
wanted to hear your thoughts on that and
I'm also you know how do I say it a big
fan of your show so you know thank you
for taking my call thank you well listen
I don't I don't remember exactly that
moment I might that must have been when
I was dealing with copyright claims when
Kamala Harris said that so I don't
remember seeing that but here's the main
thing with the uber and lyft I'll check
it out though so here's the thing if you
there are too many people who are not
considering the cost of gas and
depreciation of their vehicle when they
are thinking about how much money they
are making from uber and lyft and
there's no question that uber and lyft
drivers are underpaid unfortunately
almost any effort to pay them more other
than chipping away at what uber and lyft
keep which they are going to be very
hesitant to give up
obviously for better or worse it's going
to lead to increased prices for the
rides passed along to the end-user now
that doesn't mean that that's bad I mean
uber and lyft rides
maybe should cost more and that would be
okay with me as long as that money was
going to the drivers that being said I
think that there are some systemic
problems going on with uber and lyft
for example uber and lyft benefit
greatly from not being the employers of
the drivers the drivers are independent
contractors and we've talked about how
Amazon uses that same strategy when they
contract out to local delivery companies
for their you know prime one day and two
day deliveries and then it's a fiasco
they're underpaid they get into
accidents and Amazon goes listen these
people don't work for us these are just
subcontractors so I think that more
needs to be done there I I don't know
that much about the proposal for $15 an
hour wage plus 15 an hour for
maintenance and gas I don't know how the
math of it adds up but the situation as
it exists right now is hugely oppressive
to the drivers 100% yeah I guess I just
want to let you know that I work for
uber full time I'm actually pulled over
right here in one of the city and one of
the streets of LA and and you know when
you calculate it look what doesn't so it
doesn't tell you and lift it and tell
you how much the driver pays well you
know sometimes you'll get in
conversations with folks and they'll be
like you know I paid $20 for this ride
and then you know afterwards you see how
much uber pays you and sometimes it'll
be like $9 $10 yeah
and it always fluctuates so sometimes
you'd like you're thinking like wow we
were just at 50% of you know of this
ride and well in that case I revisit
maybe maybe the place that a lot of the
money should be coming from is uber and
lyft Skutt I mean that that if that's
the case then and then one more thing I
just wanted to make I guess a quick plug
for a the organization that you know
organized yesterday's event it was the
mobile workers Alliance whether there's
any you know drive they're listening to
your show you know I definitely would
like for them to get involved you know
it's we need to you know fight back
because it's very
unfair and then the last thing I'm going
to talk to you about there was yeah I
was watching your sing on your stream on
Twitch yesterday and I guess I did it
something go down or oh yeah we got a
copy
we got a copyright strike and I was
banned for twitch for 24 hours but we're
not gonna dwell on the negative amount
I'm Tony oh really appreciate your phone
call and whatever good luck out there
you what amend it alright we will
hopefully talk to him again
hi caller rating very very high collar
rating